Hola Daniela claro la noticia de Pelé
que era algo un poco que se esperaba que
ocurriera Pero lo podemos recordar como
un ídolo de la cultura popular pensaría
yo es decir hay figuras en el fútbol que
trascienden más allá de lo que lograron
en el campo y finalmente Pelé como puede
uno también tomar el ejemplo de Diego
Maradona e incluso Leonel Messi si lo
vemos Ya en retrospectiva son hombres
que hacen parte de la cultura popular es
decir No son no son propietarios ningún
país de ellos Más allá de que claro
Brasil obviamente se adjudica y tres
corazones que fue el lugar donde nació
Pelé se adjudica su nacimiento bueno él
termina siendo un hombre que hace parte
del mundo entero termina siendo ese
lugar de la iconografía Popular que
determina y trasciende más allá de su
propia profesión Y eso hizo Pelé como
han hecho otros futbolistas Como hizo
Diego Maradona como ha hecho Lionel
Messi yo creo que lo podemos recordar
desde ese lugar desde desde un hombre
que maravilló al mundo con su fútbol
desde un hombre que hizo grandes hazañas
con Santos con la selección brasileña
pero también fue un hombre que encarnó
de alguna manera El Avance en el
marketing deportivo él convierte de
alguna forma la posibilidad de hacer
grandes posibilidades
de marketing convierte su nombre en una
firma y en una Marca Registrada y se
convierte también en un icono mundial
del fútbol casi que en una convención
casi que una señal de lo que valida el
fútbol alrededor del mundo yo creo que
así podemos recordar a Pelé que no
solamente como les digo hizo grandes
generalidades en la cancha sino también
en temas de marketing recuerdo cuando yo
era niño el primer videojuego que uno
podía optar alguna vez era Soccer que
era un videojuego de atari él consiguió
eso consiguió abrir el fútbol hacia los
Estados Unidos un lugar que parecía
inhóspito para que llegara el que ellos
llaman soccer en fin él ha logrado una
cantidad de cosas y su leyenda y su
legado seguramente Será muy importante
teniendo en cuenta como esas grandes
figuras iconográficas de la estatura no
sé de Marilyn Monroe de hombres que han
hecho y que han trascendido Más allá de
su propia profesión Nicolás peleega ganó
tres veces el mundial Pero qué tan
difícil era en el fútbol en esa época en
la que jugó Pelé ganar tres mundiales
para Lionel Messi fue muy difícil llegar
a ganar su primer mundial Después de
varios de haber disputado de hacer
considerado también el mejor del mundo
en esta época en ese momento que como
como era el el tema qué tan difícil era
jugar ganar un mundial
era muy difícil Daniela muy difícil
porque obviamente había menos menos
exigencias era menos físico el fútbol en
cuanto a a correr y a recorrer
kilómetros y a las estadísticas que hoy
por hoy a veces como que nos perturban
frente a lo que significa este deporte
pero en esa época complicadísimo porque
no había perdón de los rivales a la hora
de maltratar a los jugadores sobre todo
a los talentosos Pelé fue víctima de
persecuciones criminales en las canchas
en el 62 más allá que él gana la Copa
del Mundo termina lesionado y en el 66
se se concibe la carnicería más violenta
contra Pelé en los partidos primero
Ultra Bulgaria en primera fase que
Brasil venía como candidato de esa Copa
del Mundo del 66 y después contra un
Grey Portugal donde moráis que era un
jugador muy talentoso le encomendaron la
misión de no dejar mover a Pelé y a Pelé
lo convirtieron en ropa de trabajo
destruyeron en ese mundial del año 66 en
goodison Park